Okay. Good. Okay. Okay. Okay. So if you would just we'll start by having you state your name
and state and location. My name is Steve Lawson. Today is August 26th 2011 and we're in a
conference room at the Valley Library. Okay. Today we'll be talking primarily about your
interactions with one is falling and specifically trying to get a better sense of
falling sort of personal characteristics. But before we get into that, too deeply I'd like you
to talk a little bit about your life starting out with sort of a thumbnail sketch of your
biography before you into the LPI in 1977. I was born in Pennsylvania in 1951 and lived there
for the first few years of life. I remember collecting donations for the Little League
World Championship is typically held in Williamsport, Pennsylvania. And Little League is big
activity in that area of North Central, Pennsylvania. We moved to Massachusetts along the coast north
of Boston in the mid to late 1950s. I'm not exactly sure of the date. But I went through elementary
school and high school in Totsfield, Massachusetts, which is a town in Essex County very close to
the Seacost. We lived in Ipswich originally, which is a coastal town in Essex County.
After graduation from high school, I went to Stanford University and I was there in Palo Alto
from 1969 to 1973. I started work at the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine in 1977
and took a full-time job there in February of 1978 and had a number of different job titles there
through the years. Eventually becoming Chief Executive Officer in 1993, about a year before
the Linus Pauling died and have worked at the Institute for most of my career.
What led you to develop your interest in science or your university member in the career?
Well, that's an interesting question. I was a little rudderless, I would say, in college.
It was very difficult for me to focus on a career. Some of my friends were very career-oriented
and became physicians and lawyers, went on to business school and so forth and that's pretty typical for
an environment of academic excellence like Stanford University. There were a lot of high
achievers there and I myself was a high achiever of course in high school. California was a big
adventure for me coming from the relatively state and conventional East Coast and it was very
wild time to be in California in 1969 through 1973 both culturally and politically.
There was a lot of anti-war activity and sentiments and of course the counter culture was really
thriving in California at that time. In high school I was very interested in science and took
advanced calculus and physics and chemistry and biology. With the idea of perhaps becoming an
architect which led me to apply to Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute as one of my college choices
because they had a very strong department of architecture. Stanford at the time had a department
of architecture as well and I decided ultimately to go to Stanford and after I got there within a
year they had completely dismantled the department of architecture so that pretty much pulled the
rug out from under me with respect to that initial potential career choice. I like science very
much I've always liked science very much I've always been very curious about nature and how things
work and I think with respect to a career in the Linus Poly Institute although I was relatively naive
about Linus Poly in high school and even in my early years in college I had been taking vitamin
supplements beginning in high school actually my mom gave me one a day multivitamin supplements
beginning probably when I was just a kid but then in the high school years my friends and I got
very interested in supplements and we're taking vitamin E and vitamin C and things like that so
the whole mission of the Linus Poly Institute really resonated with me and that led me to a position
there in 1977 that really was not science oriented at that time it was more related to analysis of
the direct male program which had been implemented within a few years before I joined the institute
and it provided a relatively steady income for a lot of the non-grant supported research
that was going on at the institute which of course in those days was most of the institute's research.
So between my graduation from Stanford and the time I joined the institute it was a fairly
carefree and adventurous some time I spent a year after graduation traveling around the country
visiting family and friends in Florida and Georgia and Maine and New England. I wanted to see
the country I'd been very impressed with John Steinbeck's books travels with Charlie and others
and also Jack Kerawak who grew up and is now buried in the same area in which I grew up in Massachusetts
so both of those writers had a very strong influence I think on me and my desires for
experience and adventure in the United States. When I returned to California
after traveling around for a year or so I took a series of jobs that really were not technical
in nature at all. Cost of living in those days was very low I think for $100 a month I could cover
my living expenses quite easily and I was not as I said career oriented at the time so I did not
feel compelled to go to graduate school or begin a career in earnest at that time and I didn't.
It wasn't until I joined the institute that I really started to focus more specifically on science
which at that time really thrilled me. Were there any you mentioned your interest in supplements
when you were in college and I assumed that pollen was probably something you were aware of
at least by the time you had graduated? Was that true and were there any other signs of your
role models or mentors you had during that time period that you come to mind? Well I began taking
vitamins probably in an irregular way when I was in high school probably you've seen you're in
high school and that continued on into my early years in college. Of course pollen had written
vitamins in the common cold in 1970 and friends in mine had open health food stores and had supplement
products as part of their the merchandise for sale so I was aware of this whole field early on
without really knowing specifically much about Linus pollen. As a matter of fact I knew very
little of Linus pollen even when I went to Stanford as a freshman it wasn't until
probably about 1972 that I became more aware of him and it didn't have anything to do with science.
At the time I don't believe he was teaching undergraduate courses in chemistry at Stanford
which would have been my possible exposure to him. I don't think he was teaching graduate level
courses at Stanford either but he was very politically active and of course this was during a lot
of pretty vehement anti-war protests around the country and Stanford was no exception to that
kind of activity and in particular there was a tenured professor of English H. Bruce Franklin who
was a Melville scholar one of the world's foremost authorities on Melville and has subsequently
done a lot of work in recognizing science fiction as an appropriate academic discipline for study
and he had joined the Revolutionary Union and also Vence Aramos which was an organization I
believe based in Redwood City California. They were very politically active. They were kind of
Maoist organizations and they really wanted not only an end to the Vietnam War but I think more
dramatic upheaval in the federal government at that time and Stanford eventually had had
enough of H. Bruce Franklin and considered I think some of his activities borderline legal
and Franklin was getting in a lot of trouble and they decided to fire him and of course he was
a tenured professor so that was a big ordeal and protocol that they had to work through in order
to fire him. Stanford trustees at the time were quite conservative and I remember walking to class
down at the quadrangle at Stanford and I saw a protest outside the president's office
and there were a group of undergraduates and other people assembled around a couple of people
waving protest signs and the signs had something to do with the university had no right to fire
a tenured professor for his political activity and I saw these two fellows holding these signs and
they look grandfatherly to me at the time and one was Linus Pauling and the other one I believe
was Hal Holman who was chairman of the Department of Medicine at Stanford University Medical Center
who was a liberal and a good friend of Linus Pauling's at the time and I remember being very
impressed with the fact that these two elderly gentlemen were taking the time out from their
busy schedules to go and actually protesting in front of the president's office. I thought that
was quite remarkable because at that time most of the political activity was concentrated among
very young people sometimes it was very random and chaotic and encoded as well but I thought it
was quite remarkable that there were older people who were also interested in demonstrating for
the rights of people to express their political opinions. So that was my first that was really my first
awareness of Linus Pauling was from the political perspective and not really from the scientific
angle. It wasn't until I joined the Linus Pauling Institute that I really became much more
familiar with Linus Pauling's work in chemistry and in biology. What were your areas that you think?
Well when I joined when I went to Stanford as I mentioned I was very interested in architecture as
a potential career so I was taking engineering and architecture while that department lasted
and I also had kind of a renaissance concept of undergraduate education at the time. I thought it
was very important to take as many courses and different subjects as possible so I was taking
calculus and biology and art history and literature and poetry and just everything that I thought
I should be exposed to as an undergraduate. I graduated with degree in anthropology in 1973 but I
probably had almost enough credits in biology for a degree in biology or at least a minor in biology
and at the time there were a couple of pretty notorious professors at Stanford who made a big
impression on me. One was Colin Pittendrig in the biology department. He I believe also was director
of the Hopkins Marine Station in Monterey, taught a terrific course in biology and also
Cachadorian. William DeMent taught a very popular course in Sleeping Dreams that was very popular among
undergraduates. Phil Pzenbardo of course was teaching very popular psychology course at the time
and he went on to some famous the leader of the Stanford Prison Experiment which was quite
influential at the time. How did you come to know about the land falling institutes and the job
we were doing in five points? Well I had lived in Memel Park or Palo Alto for many years. The
institute was founded in 1973 on Sandhill Road opposite the Stanford linear accelerator and at that
time that part of Sandhill Road primarily the northern side of Sandhill Road headed west
was a series of relatively new buildings on Tom Ford property he was a trustee of Stanford
University and there were publishing companies and real estate companies and insurance companies.
Now that area is a high of venture capitalist activity but the institute in those days I believe
the 2700 Sandhill Road shared relatively modern office building with Kemper Insurance Company
and I was aware of the sign out on the street so I driven by there many times on my way to the
coastal range or to the beach and I think that if I remember correctly I saw an advertisement in the
paper specifically for a job without a lot of detailed description about the nature of the job
and I went to interview at the Linus Plain Institute of Science and Medicine and interviewed with
Art Robinson who was then the president and director of the institute and he hired me.
Do you recall the first time the event was falling?
Well the first time I saw him of course was as I said back in about probably 1972 when he was
demonstrating against the firing of H. Bruce Franklin. I met him in 1977 because my office was
just off the hallway that Pauline took to get to his office which was adjacent to Art Robinson's
office and also the the accountant and controller were down at the end of that office as well
and he was very aware of who was working at the institute and what all the activities were and he
stopped in to introduce himself to me when I was sitting in my office one day and of course I was
I had remembered him from Stanford and I had become more aware of his scientific legend
the course by then by working at the Linus Plain Institute and I was also aware of the fact
that this was his institute and it was named after him so of course I had I had high regard for him
as being the founder of this organization that I was now working for but he impressed me as a very
warm charming very friendly person who was not cerebral or distant at all not a luke who was very
very welcoming. What's he frequently around the institute? I mean I know he traveled a lot but
we recall him being the regular presence on the early days. He did travel quite a lot but I do
remember him being a regular presence certainly when he was in town he would come by the institute
that was his office and his main base of operations and if he had to do interviews or see guests it
was typically at the Linus Plain Institute in his office and I remember meeting many of his friends
at that time including an emissary from St. George's lab at Woods Hole I believe his name was
I can't think of his name right now it started with a P he was very interested in
telling us about St. George's new theories regarding vitamin C and the electronic basis of life
vitamin C as an electron donor being very essential to life far above its role in preventing scurvy or
as antioxidant. Dorothy Hodgkin also came through the institute at that time and it was fairly soon
after I arrived at the institute that I also met you in Cameron who of course was a Scottish
surgeon who was collaborating intensively with Linus Pauling on vitamin C and cancer work.
I did I met Dorothy Hodgkin at that time I believe I was working the laboratory.
I had begun a friendship with a biochemist named Alan Sheetz at the institute as well as Dick
Willoughby who was a biologist working on the skin cancer and vitamin C experiments that Pauling
had designed and were being carried out by Art Robinson at the time and as arts influence in the
institute started to wane people responsible for a lot of the biological biochemical work were
encouraging me to get more involved in that work. I seem to have the aptitude for it I was
quite interested in it so I moved out of the role that I was originally hired to perform at the
institute which was this direct male solicitation work and analysis into kind of a research assistant
position in the labs and that led me to come in contact with people that Pauling would bring
through the laboratory to to show them the work that we were doing. Bill Abarth at the time was
running a volcano source filled ionization mass spectrometer which was used for metabolite
profiling which was a big chunk of the institute's research at the time so people were always
interested in coming down to the first floor and seeing that rubbed gold bird contraption which
was always undergoing tinkering never seemed to be quite ready for routine biological experimentation
and since I was working the laboratory at that time I would meet people that Pauling would bring
through the laboratory and one of them with Dorothy Hodgkin. So Pauling you were hired in 1977
and LPI and have filled the career there Pauling lived until 1994 so that's a 17-year period
and one evening you can just generally characterize your relationship with Pauling how he evolved over
those 17 years. Sure well originally I saw little of him because my work did really not overlap
with his research interests I mean of course he was heavily involved in the financial status
in the institute and Art Robinson was the main force behind the direct male solicitation program
but Pauling was certainly aware of that and once I started working in the laboratory more
we had more to talk about and I became heavily involved in the skin cancer and hairless mice program
which was testing the effect of different levels of vitamin C in a mouse chow diet
on the development of skin cancer in hairless mice exposed to ultraviolet light
and other arms of those experiments and there were a number of experiments that took place over
a number of years some of the other arms of that project involved feeding raw food and nuts
to mice to see whether that also inhibited the development of skin cancer when the mice were exposed
to ultraviolet light so the mice were given things like carrots and pears and sunflower seeds
tomatoes and other raw food to find out what effect that would have and when Art Robinson left
Pauling of course was interested in finding out how this work was going and he asked me to
I believe the first project that he asked me specifically to get involved in was to calculate
the amount of certain micronutrients in the food that these mice were fed
because as scientists we tend to be a little reductionist we want to find out if there is an
effect with the whole food then what is it in the food that might be protective
so that was a very challenging project that Pauling gave to me and I was a bit frustrated because
the way that the food had been provided to the mice made it very difficult to determine
how much an individual mouse consumed of any particular food stuff the mice were also caged
five to a cage and there were social patterns that developed of hierarchy that developed within
the cage so there were dominant mice who would eat the preferred food and then the less dominant
mice would get what was left so there was some competition for the best food the most flavorful
food for the mice the way the food was provided to them was sometimes as a mush ground up or blended
food and sometimes as chunks of carrots and pears and so forth the sunflower seeds were given to
them and small glass containers with metal lids that had a hole in them and the mice would spray
the sunflower seeds out all over the place and it was really impossible to determine the intake
of any of these foods for specific animal and even for a cage of animals divided by five was really
not appropriate calculation there was a lot of waste so a lot of the food would fall through the
mesh to the floor to the to the cage rack and sometimes they would defecate and urinate in the
sunflower seed container as well and then wouldn't continue to eat once they'd already defecated
or urinated in that container there were other issues as well for instance the vitamin A content
of carrots can differ appreciably depending upon how long the carrots are stored after they've been
picked and that was something that was not measured at the time so there was no analysis
biochemical analysis of the food that was provided to the animals and depending upon the variety
ripeness length of time something had been stored whether it was refrigerated or stored at room
temperature the micronutrient content of the foodstuffs provided to the mice could very
appreciably so I made the calculations and I sat down with Linus Pauling and told him that in my
estimation it was really impossible to glean any really useful detailed information about the
micronutrient intake of these animals and that the best we could do was say that the raw food
diet seemed to be protective but it was it was just too difficult to determine what constituents
in the raw food diet conferred that protection so it was a little bit I was a little bit ambivalent
about that I think I did a very thorough and and good job in making these determinations but
ultimately what I had to say was a little bit disappointing I think oh he didn't react with
disappointment he he reacted as you know I was presenting him with facts and calculations and he
was very seemed very pleased to get the information was not long after that that you and Cameron
began spending quite a lot more time at the institute and I believe they've taken an apartment
nearby maybe redwood city and Cameron of course was very interested in high dose vitamin C
as a junk to therapy and cancer as was Pauling and they had done some clinical work together
over the years beginning probably in 1971-1972 so it even preceded the founding
of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine and Cameron was concerned with some of the
practical issues about the administration of high dose vitamin C to cancer patients
who might also be taking chemotherapy drugs and we know that vitamin C has some general detox
detoxification properties and Cameron specifically was concerned that if people were taking
chemotherapy drugs then should they take high dose vitamin C at the same time which might have
an effect on the efficacy of the chemotherapy drugs so he didn't want to recommend to people that
they take high dose vitamin C while taking chemotherapy if the vitamin C was going to somehow adversely
affect these drugs so he wanted to find a way to study this and in association with Linus Pauling
and Alan Sheetz we came up with the idea of using fish toxicology experiments which is a pretty
well-established model for studying pollution in streams and lakes and bodies of water and things
like that so we read a lot about fish toxicology Alan and I figured out how to reconstitute water
from distilled water by adding back certain salts to provide the proper habitat for fingering trout
and the idea was that we would have fingering trout that would be exposed to vitamin C and
chemotherapy of drugs dissolved in their water that they were living in and we would monitor any
observable effects in the fish and we hypothesized that they would be detected by abnormal
behavior in the fish which would have to do with the way they swim the distance that they cover
in a certain period of time and so forth so there was some technology that was also developed to
make these kinds of measurements so that was another project that I worked with you and Cameron
and Linus Pauling unfortunately we had to vacate the building at 2700 Sand Hill Road in Menlo Park
ostensibly because there had been cracks in the building due to small earthquakes over time it wasn't
a building that was set on bedrock it was on loose soil and the landlord wanted to get the tenants
out make some structural corrections in the building and I don't think the landlord was overly excited
by a laboratory in the building anyway we were sharing the building with Kemper insurance company
and I think he was more happy with having nice dry insurance company and having wet labs there
with animal experiments and physics experiments and so forth so those experiments had to be wrapped
up before we really brought them to fruition before we moved to the facility at 440 page mill road
in Palo Alto. Were there other scientific collaborations with Pauling and over the course of your
relationship? There were he would come into my office from time to time and we would talk about
ideas he had different projects that he was interested in occasionally he would ask me if I would
be interested in doing something like writing a book review which was a little surprising but
when Evelyn Richards book Vitamin C in Cancer Medicine or Politics was published I believe in 1991
or 1992 Linus Pauling came into my office with a copy of the book and asked me if I would be
interested in writing a book review to be submitted to a nutrition journal and I've of course
said yes and wrote the review which was subsequently published in a nutrition journal. Later
and of course I would go into his office from time to time and talk with him about different
things the quantum chemist by the name of Zele Cymon who was collaborating with Pauling and problems
in theoretical chemistry and physics over the whole period in the late 1970s through Pauling's
death. Zele Cymon and I were both rock hounds we had collected rocks and minerals when we were
kids and we knew that Pauling was was a great mineralologist and understood a lot about the
silicate minerals which are quite interesting so the three of us would amuse ourselves occasionally
by Zele Cymon and I would bring in some of our mineral specimens and we would sit in Pauling's
office and try to stump the expert essentially sometimes Zele Cymon and I would have forgotten the
identifications of some of the minerals we had so they would be presented to Dr. Pauling to see
if he could identify them and it was astonishing because even though he had probably not thought
about some of these things in many many years or even decades he infallibly was able to identify
the mineral and make a fairly quick identification so that was fun it didn't have anything to do with
any of the research going on at the institute but it was very fun to sit and talk with him in
that way. Later in the late 1980s and I'm going to say probably around 1988 Pauling came into my
office with an idea for a new technique to fabricate superconductive material and this was during kind
of a heyday of resurgence of interest in ceramic superconductors but Pauling had a vastly different idea
which had to do with the way a material could be fabricated and perhaps that would raise the
temperature which would be superconductive and it had to do with, excuse me, phonon dampening
and his idea was that if you could have a conductive metal like tin drawn to an incredibly
fine fibral as he called it maybe 10 or 20 angstroms in diameter surrounded by
insulating material like glass then the superconductive temperature of the tin would be increased the
TC of the tin would be raised and he talked with me about some ideas that he had and how to make
this material which he believed would be important in supporting a patent application that he wanted
to file and his goal I think in filing this patent application as he described it to me and
others was to generate a stable revenue source for the institute so he wasn't interested in an
acquiring wealth on his own but he was interested in looking for revenue sources for the institute
which had lurched from one financial crisis to another throughout my whole tenure at the
Linus Bond Institute of Science and Medicine and he thought that this might be something that
could be licensed and would generate lots of income so Zele Kerman and I set up a laboratory
at Stanford Industrial Park at a least facility that the institute had on Porter Drive
which also has the Sasakawa aging research facility and some storage area and we set up a laboratory
bought an oven some torches blow torches compress gas borosilicate glass tin and Zeke had developed
a very interesting way to collect the material that we were going to produce which was a bicycle
inverted on a block of wood and we had taken the rubber tire off the bike rim and we wanted to
collect this glass clad fibrill of tin that we would generate with torches above the furnace
and then connect it to the bicycle wheel and then use the pedals or a crank to turn the bicycle
rim and then we would collect in a circular fashion this long piece of glass that was filled with tin.
So there was a lot of trial and error involved in that and you and Kerman was aware of what we were
doing as well and he developed kind of a special interest in this as well so you and Kerman and
Zele Kerman and I spent quite a lot of time in this laboratory at Porter Drive trying to produce
this material and it was interesting in another way as well in that Pauline was very interested in
seeing the laboratory notebooks and wanted to be sure that we were taking copious and meticulous
notes on what we were doing and the laboratory notebook page for instance had to be signed and
dated and then periodically I believe once a week or once every two weeks someone who was not
associated with the project was asked to read what had been put in the laboratory notebook and
countersign it so typically we asked Emil Zucacamba who was the president of the institute at that time
to read what we'd written in the lab notebook and then he would countersign it and dated as well
which was when I was working as a scientist at the institute I think I was aware of
how important it is to maintain good protocol in filling out data and laboratory notebooks you
don't erase things you cross them out glue or tape things in use pen date and so forth so that in
the future people who are unfamiliar with your work could theoretically be able to go back and
repeat what you've done based only on the information provided in the lab notebook and that
was that concept was really driven home through this work for Linus Pauline because he was very
interested in us maintaining very meticulous laboratory notebook which we did he was quite happy
with it and after many months of trial and error and kind of a sophisticated development of this
technique an examination of the product through high power magnification we were able to come up
with material that we thought would be suitable needed to be tested of course to see whether or not
the superconductive temperature had changed but Pauline was just ecstatic at that time he was in
an apartment in Stanford and we Zeke and I were very excited and we brought a sample of this
down to his apartment and he himself was very excited it was it was I can imagine that he exhibited
this kind of emotion many times throughout his life whenever he made an important scientific
discovery or became aware of an important discovery that influenced his own work but he just
looked joyful and he immediately went over to the mantle the fireplace and got a big cubic
pyrite crystal and gave one to me and gave something to Zeke and then said be sure to bring your
copies of General Chemistry in and unscribe them on the occasion of this happy happy discovery
invention that we've made and that work formed the basis for his patent application and I believe
his patent for novel technique for fabricating superconductive material was awarded in perhaps 1991
I think there were initial applications submitted as early as 1988-1989 but I think that the final
application was granted the final patent was granted in 1991. Was that technique ever employed on
any of them? Well it would turn out to be very difficult to measure changes in superconductivity
in this material because if you can imagine getting an appropriate contact between the end of
this tin fibrill that was maybe 10 to 20 angstroms in diameter was extremely difficult. We sent
the material off to General Electric and connected he Pauling had contacted a number of his friends
in industry to find out if they had equipment that might be capable of measuring making these
measurements for us. So there were problems in actually making the measurements but the Vice
President of the Institute Rick Hicks at the time felt that since we had the patent in hand
we should try to license it. So he embarked on a process of trying to identify companies in the
United States that might be interested in licensing this technology and he wasn't having much success
in this country he went to Japan I believe in probably about 1991 or 1992 and tried to shop it
around there also without I'm sure there was interest expressed but there was nothing that was
really consummated at the time and it led to kind of an interesting exchange some time later
when Rick had returned from Asia some months had gone by Emil Zucacondle called me on the intercom
if I would come down to his office because we had a visitor and I went down to his office and we
had someone there from the Central Intelligence Agency who was very interested in this particular
invention and wanted to know why we were shopping this around in Japan and other countries rather
than the United States and I explained to him that well the reason was we hadn't been able to find
anyone in the United States who was was interested I thought it was quite interesting that the CIA seemed
to know about this that was pretty much the end of that I think there was a miscue later
that had to do with the turmoil surrounding Pauling's death and
succession of people in charge of the institute and files being shifted around and so forth and
somehow the application to continue the maintenance fee on that particular patent fell through
the cracks so I think that I think the reason that it died effectively was because the maintenance
fee was not paid unfortunately or any other side of the collaborations of no point.
Not really I think that the vitamin C and skin cancer experiments of course I was co-author of
one of the papers that resulted from that work and in the superconductive material were the two major
collaborations. How do you describe Pauling's style of the scientists and what do you observe
where I think the greatest strengths of the scientists? Well he as many people have remarked had an
encyclopedic knowledge of physics, chemistry, biology, perhaps medicine, mathematics, statistics
had an incredibly good grasp of statistics and that served him very well I think as a scientist
because he was as I like to say perhaps the best embodiment of the multidisciplinary or interdisciplinary
attack on scientific problems and of course that's a buzz word in science today and that's
what the NIH and funding agencies encourage is kind of team activity but it was remarkable that
this kind of knowledge expansive and encyclopedic knowledge was exhibited in one particular person
in Linus Pauling which I think was quite remarkable so his memory as well his ability to extract
references and facts and material from other papers and so forth that span most of his life was
quite remarkable so I think those two things served him incredibly well as a scientist and I saw
that in action many times when he could cite other literature and talk about what other people had
found and so forth so I was very impressed by his grasp of science and his memory and he also
struck me as being very courageous as I said earlier my first exposure to him in the political arena
I thought he was quite courageous at that time later I became aware of just how courageous he was
when he was facing the US Senate with respect to allegations of his lack of patriotism or something
like that and he basically stood them down which I thought was incredibly courageous and in another
sense he was a very courageous scientist when Zalik and I were working with this furnace in the late
1980s at Porter Drive Pauling would come up from time to time and one time in particular he put
on a lab coat and put on gloves and goggles and was wielding the torch above the 800 degree furnace
as well so he was actively engaged in this experimental project which I thought was quite extraordinary
so he didn't really prefer to just sit at his desk and think about things he also wanted to get
hands on when something really intrigued him or interested him and during the mouse skin cancer
experiments as well he would often come through the laboratory just to check on things see how things
were going ask people questions about the work that was underway and so forth so he was not
removed from the experimental side of things although clearly he was involved in a lot of other
things and didn't actually participate physically in a lot of the experimental work in those days he
he didn't he wasn't a stranger in the laboratory and I witnessed that first hand with the work
on superconductivity where he actually was engaged experimentally and I think that was probably
the last experimental work that he was engaged in because at that time he probably would have been
in his late 1980s this was the late 1980s so he was in his late 80s as well
over time you your role days to change from that of scientific researcher to more of the
administrator and I'm wondering if you engage in other different kinds of work with Pauling in
that context of the administrator. Very much so I had asked I had been asked to become a
assistant to the president when he meals with the president of the institute at the time I was
co-director with a meal of the laboratory for research and gene regulation and we had a small
research group we were looking at problems and cancer metastasis using protein profiling techniques
which had just recently been developed and we were developing instrumentation that would allow us
to increase reproducibility and reduce noise in the experimental procedure and we were very
interested in discovering genes and proteins that might correlate with the metastatic the
development of the metastatic phenotype in both marine and human cancer cells excuse me
so I was also working a bit administratively with a meal zucacondle at that time and then when
a meal retired from the institute on the occasion of his birthday there was quite a lot of
turmoil at the institute because there are a number of problems one problem was the institute as
I mentioned earlier had a history of financial instability and over the years under a meal's direction
the institute expanded quite significantly to include some projects that probably would not be
considered strictly in the realm of orthomolecular medicine of course which was Pauling's
most I think the reason he set up the institute to begin with and something that he felt strongest
about so I think a meal may have had a desire for the institute to become a more comprehensive
institute of molecular biological and chemical and biological sciences similar to the
Salk Institute down in southern California which is a fine template but there weren't
enough grants won by institute staff to support all the varied activities that were going on
so concomitant with a meal's retirement and the retirement of Rick Hicks from the institute
there was a shift in focus in the institute and the board of trustees decided that
there really weren't enough funds to sustain all the varied programs underway at the institute so
the idea was to pair back some of the strictly molecular biological work that wasn't funded
extramarially by government grants from DOE or NIH or NCI or whatever and refocus specifically on
orthomolecular medicine and at about that time Linus Pauling had begun a friendship and scientific
collaboration with a German cardiologist Matthias Rat who together with Pauling had developed some
interesting hypotheses about the relationship of lipoprotein A which is a risk factor for
orthosis and a major constituator at the risk of erotic plaque and vitamin C and they published
a number of hypothesis papers a very famous one being in PNAS and developed decided to set up a
laboratory for cardiovascular disease research that was directed by Dr. Rat and Pauling was very
excited about this work when and at some point and I don't remember the exact time but it was
after a meal had retired and Pauling became for short time the president and director of the
institute after a meal he asked me to become his assistant and I wasn't quite sure what that
meant so I had written him a note or memo asking him what he wanted me to do and I had some ideas
mainly of administrative nature as to things that I thought could result in big improvements in
the way the institute was was run and our financial status and other issues but he disappeared
to Big Sur to his ranch down in the coast of California for some time and I felt a little adrift
and by this time I had gotten to know Linus Plain Jr fairly well because he was I think in the
process of getting more actively involved in the administration of the institute because he
recognized his father was ill and there were a lot of problems at the institute and he felt he
should step in to help his father which I thought was very commendable and eventually I became
the executive officer at the institute which was similar in function to being president of the
institute and then later the board appointed me chief executive officer I think in about 1993
technically I became chief executive officer so throughout this period where I functioned in
different administrative roles I worked very closely with Linus Plain Jr the board of trustees
and of course by that time Linus Plain had become chairman of the board of trustees and
director of research at the institute but didn't really have an administrative role any longer
in the Linus Plain Institute of Science and Medicine because I think everyone felt that it would
be best if he were spared the problems that we had to resolve and there were problems concerning
relocation it was a zoning issue where the least property on which our building was situated at
440 Page Mill Road in Palo Alto was scheduled to change from commercial to residential zoning
quite quickly and no one range plans had really been developed to deal with that zoning change
and we didn't have an endowment had very little money so the prospect of moving the institute
trying to keep it intact in the mid peninsula but paying maybe ten or twenty times more in rent
was not very encouraging and Linus Plain himself of course had been diagnosed with prostate
cancer and although he was undergoing a number of different experimental therapies it was not
believed that he would survive his illness and we were very concerned about what would happen to
the institute after his death would we be able to continue to raise money to support the institute
as a viable research organization and then of course there were lawsuits and there was quite a
lot of litigation at that time Matthias Rat had left the institute and it sued the institute for
infringement in his business activities and also sued Linus Pauling so I had to manage a lot
of our litigation at that time as well so my role at the time the big challenges were finding a
future home or at least the disposition of the Linus Plain is to do the science and medicine
keeping it intact and reputable and also managing our litigation which was very burdensome
and took absorbed a lot of my time and a lot of the boards time as well but Pauling was largely
spared from that I mean he was deposed of course a number of times but I managed a lot of our
legal affairs at that time in close association with Linus Plain Jr was the chairman of the board
and at that time we had very regular board meetings as well so the board of trustees was kept
well apprised of all the activities and their opinions were solicited in many of these activities as
well so it was a very challenging time for me I was surprised to be honest when the board asked me
to become chief executive officer because it kind of came out of the blue the work that I was doing
with a musica condo was not really related to orthomolecular medicine wasn't related to vitamin C
at the time as I said we were looking at metastatic cancer which really had nothing to do with
orthomolecular medicine so I was concerned that my group and my job were in jeopardy as well
because there were rumors circulating that the board wanted to refocus on orthomolecular medicine
and since my work wasn't involved in orthomolecular medicine I thought perhaps I might be laid
off from the institute as well at about the same time a musica condo wanted to collect some of the
people who were doing molecular biological work in a new institute called the institute of molecular
medical sciences which he hoped to rent space from the Linus-Plying Institute of Science and Medicine
in the same building so I spent quite a lot of time as executive officer with Zele Kerman
analyzing that proposition trying to figure out whether it was practical and if so
how building expenses should be shared between the two groups and so forth so I spent quite a lot
of time in those kinds of deliberations at that time too and eventually we came up with the
recommendation to Linus-Plying and the board. One of Pauline's some calling cards of Caltech
anyway then the goal was here at the Caltech was his ability to collect and marshal and oversee
tremendous talent of scientific researches or the graduate students or postdocs and I'm
wondering if you adhered to some sort of dynamic going on over the course of your time at LCI
which is the ability to collect talent and make it efficient productive.
Well I think our Robinson is a terrific scientist and art of course was working very close
with Linus-Plying at the University of California San Diego and then came up to run his lab and
and collaborate with research at Stanford and there's no question that Dr. Robinson was an
extraordinarily capable scientist and with Pauline developed lots of very interesting ideas
so that was one person that he worked with over that period of time that I had a lot of
respect for and I think Pauline had a lot of respect for at least until there was a big
schism that developed between them which was very painful to watch especially at that time I was
not really privy to a lot of the major administrative decisions at the institute so it was a little
unclear as to why this conflict had developed but it was very difficult an uncomfortable time
for everyone I think at the institute. Excuse me. Bill Aberg, I'm Bill Aberg, a physicist was
also a very extraordinarily talented individual who was developing the mass spectrometer for
metabolite profiling. Emil Zucacondle who had developed the idea of chemical paleogenetics
or molecular evolution with Pauline earlier in the 1960s was an extraordinarily bright capable
scientist. He was also the founding editor of the journal of molecular evolution and was
one of those rare individuals who's capable of sustaining simultaneously many complex thoughts
and I saw this in action many times I have tremendous respect and admiration for Emil Zucacondle.
He was really an extraordinary scientist and theorist so yes there were people of extraordinarily
high caliber that were involved with the institute and of course there were collaborations as well
and some of Pauline's collaborators would visit the institute from time to time.
There were a few problems in that since the institute did not have
stable financial resources or an endowment it was difficult to attract high caliber scientists.
There were high caliber scientists who were employed at the institute John Levitt,
Jim Fleming, Greg Spicer, there were a number of people that were very very good
at viewing camera and as a medical director but it was difficult because not much could be offered
to people other than at will contract which was the way that most contract most employment is
handled in California unless you have an employment contract and it was imprudent to offer employment
contracts to people so initially it was kind of an implied at will employment arrangement
with people and then later in the early 1990s it became very explicit at will employment
relationship with employees but nevertheless there were people who were attracted to the
institute because of Linus Pong because of his interest in vitamin C Dr. Connie Chow and others
who did a lot of really terrific work at willcott.com just to mention a few but there were a number of
really excellent people there of physicians and scientists who did a lot of very good work over the
years and in those days it was also very difficult to get expect and get funding from the
National Institutes of Health or the National Cancer Institute for the kind of work that Pauline
was especially interested in which had to do with vitamin C in cancer so I'm sure you're aware
of his difficulty in getting grants to carry out this kind of research with the very promising
clinical work that Cameron had been doing in Scotland Pauline and Cameron went to the NCI with
that work repeatedly and they suggested that he applied for funds to do animal work and soul
culture work and he applied for those funds and was turned down repeatedly over seminary
consecutive years so the money that was supported that kind of work at the institute was sought from
the public through this direct mail solicitation campaign and that was the money that was available
to pay the researchers who were doing that work. Pauline is remembering that also famously
being a terrific lecture and I wonder if you could comment on that your experience in seeing him
the lecture and his facility in that regard. Yes I didn't see him lecture very often I saw him
lectures at Stanford University and of course he would give the famous vitamin C lecture where he
would stand on stage and pull from his he typically wore a three-piece suit when he was giving a lecture
a dark suit sometimes he would wear his beret and he would invariably begin his lectures on
vitamin C by pulling out a vial a test tube and holding it up with his fingers with a very small
amount of a white powder at the bottom that was barely detectable from the audience perspective
and you would say this is this represents the RDA for vitamin C this is the amount of vitamin C
that the food nutrition board believes that people should should get every day and he would follow
that by pulling by pulling out a large test tube with 13 grams of vitamin C in it and you could
obviously see all this white powder and the vial from across the auditorium and he would say this
is the amount of vitamin C that a goat synthesizes on average every day I think goats know more about
nutrition than the food nutrition board and of course that always got got a big round of applause
and chuckles from the audience one lecture I saw him give which really stood out in my mind
was a lecture departmental lecture to biostatistics at Stanford and that department
was chaired by Byron Brown who was a leading biostatistician and the Stanford Department of
Biostatistics is world renowned they've been world renowned for many decades and Byron Brown
was the father of a classmate of mine from Stanford so I knew him and he had become aware of
Pauling's work with Abram Hauffer on a regimen provided adjunctively to cancer patients which
included not only vitamin C but also B vitamins vitamin E zinc and some other things and Pauling
and Hauffer had published two papers on this regimen and Pauling believed that it was even more effective
than the sole use of vitamin C which was given either intravenously or orally sometimes both
by Ewing Cameron and Scotland and they had and Pauling had developed a statistical analysis of
this data based on work done by an old friend of his from UC Berkeley by the name of Harden Jones
and Pauling believed that this statistical analysis was better than the standard Kaplan Meyer
mortality analysis because by using Harden Jones analysis you could actually resolve sub cohorts
that had similar death rates and you might be able to learn more about these sub cohorts with
with similar death rates so he thought that this was was a better way to analyze mortality data
from from clinical studies and he published also I think was Ella Kerman and perhaps it was
PNAS on this Harden Jones analysis of mortality data and he was invited by Byron Brown to give a
lecture to the biostatisticians at Stanford on this Harden Jones mortality data and of course
at the time everybody was using Kaplan Meyer which is the standard step staircase type curve that
you see published in papers and I went with Pauling and Herman to that lecture which was in a large
conference room over at Stanford and it was astonishing how little criticism he got from this
analysis I think he was prepared to be well he was never really defensive about anything because
he was very sure of his own intelligence and his own analysis but no one had any serious criticisms
of his analysis and people were saying that well perhaps we should we should look at this more
carefully and perhaps this does offer a better alternative to Kaplan Meyer analysis in some circumstances
it was quite extraordinarily quite extraordinary to see some of the world's leading biostatisticians
react that way to something that was fairly novel and and something that was certainly not
standardly employed in in this kind of analysis and it was quite interesting to see him present
present that analysis I'm wondering if you could speak a little bit more about Pauling
as a mentor as well as yourself or others as well he was very encouraging and as I said he was
not a Louvre so it was very easy person to speak with I think at the time that I got to know
him of course he was in his 80s and at that time he was considered kind of an icon in science and
everyone was extraordinarily respectful to Linus Pauling no one at the institute called him by his
first name for instance it was always Professor Pauling or Dr. Pauling even Dorothy Monroe the
secretary and assistant called him Dr. Pauling and typically Zele Curman would call him Professor Pauling
Emilio Zucacondo typically called him Dr. Pauling as did Rick Hicks and so I think that was
a measure of respect that all the people at the institute had for him he was also very
interested in in people on a personal basis as well and I remember when he had decided not to
drive so much himself anymore from his apartment on Stanford campus to the institute which was
just a mile or two away people would volunteer to drive him from his apartment to the institute
and then take him back to his apartment at the end of the day and I did that quite often because
I enjoyed talking with him and I also enjoyed to have an uninterrupted period with him where he was
free from telephone calls and appointments and other distractions because there were a lot of demands
on his time throughout his career I imagine and at the institute there were always people calling
wanting to interview him wanting him to give lectures and so forth and wanting to visit him
so it was rare to have an occasion to actually talk with him one-on-one with no distractions and
he would occasionally ask me about my long-term aspirations and make suggestions and he would
often tell me stories he loved to tell stories about things that had happened to him
that were based on work that we were doing at the institute or that might have been stimulated
by a comment I would make to him and I remember one time this is a little off topic because it
doesn't have anything to do with mentorship but I think it gives you some insight into
his sense of humor during one of these trips where I was taking him to the institute
he told me that he had been over at the Stanford Library to look at an old issue of nature
or science from close to the early part of the 20th century close to the turn of the century
and this was when David Starr Jordan was president of Stanford University,
Leland Stanford who was chairman of the board, David Starr Jordan was an ornithologist, excuse me
Iqtheologist who had written books on academic books on fish and he was president of the
university at that time as well as being a scholar and Pauling had been looking through an old issue
of nature and for a specific article but this other story caught his eye and it had to do with
a controversy that had developed at Stanford between David Starr Jordan and Leland Stanford
and Leland Stanford apparently had become unhappy with David Starr Jordan because during
trustees meetings Jordan did not refer the trustees by name and Stanford thought that this was
not civil and perhaps even borderline rude not to refer to them by name and he had implored
Jordan to learn the names of the trustees and in subsequent meetings to refer to them by name
and Jordan's retort apparently to Stanford was well I'm afraid if I enforce to memorize the name
of a trustee I'll forget the name of a fish and Pauling thought that was hilarious
and it gives you an idea of what he valued because I think he was definitely on the side of
Jordan in that argument. Do you recall any other stories from a drive time?
Oh there were lots of other stories one time it wasn't during a drive but it was when
I was negotiating in contract with Unilever and Elizabeth Arden who had
decided to develop a line of cosmetics that included some antioxidants and wanted to
get the institute involved in this not in a research and development capacity but they wanted to
support some research at the institute and provide us with a lot of money and I've been talking
many times with Linus Pauling about this prospect and went in to talk with him in his office
about it and he said oh he remembered one time that he and Abe Helen had gone to visit Lord
Leaver in England and had brought along a bottle of scotch whiskey as a present and it was in
their bag and they got to Lord Leaver's castle or home and they were met by servants who immediately
took their bags and they were ushered in to see Lord Leaver and Pauling and his wife were chatting
with him and Pauling remembered that he had a gift so he wanted to excuse himself and go to his
room and get the gift for Lord Leaver and he went up to his room and the servants had already
unpacked their bags put clothes in the drawers or hanging in the closet and they'd also taken out
the bottle of whiskey and uncapped it and had two jiggers there ready for Pauling and his wife
because they believed that Pauling had brought this along to serve himself so he thought it was
very funny that he had to present Lord Leaver were the body of bottle of whiskey that had already
been opened but he explained to him why it had been open and one other story that I thought was
quite indicative of Pauling's character was told to me by you and Cameron and Cameron of course
had been collaborating very closely with Pauling and Pauling had decided to visit Cameron at his
home in Wachlum inside on a trip that he was making to England and Cameron told me that he was
a little bit ambivalent about this visit by the great man of science to his humble home in Scotland
and he was worried that it wouldn't be presentable enough so he and his wife made elaborate preparations
to welcome Linus Pauling and his wife to their humble home in Scotland and the day that Pauling arrived
Pauling arrived and within half an hour before Pauling had arrived the toilet stopped up and
Cameron hadn't had time to do anything about it before the arrival of Linus Pauling and his wife
so Pauling and his wife arrived and they came in and pleasantries were exchanged and Cameron showed
them around the home in the view and so forth and Pauling asked to use the bathroom and Cameron
said which I'm very very sorry it's characteristic way but there seems to be a problem with the
toilet and Pauling so what's the problem and Cameron explained to him the toilet had just gotten
stopped up and he hadn't had time to do anything and Pauling said well let's go in and fix it
so Cameron was a bit of gasp but said okay so the two of them went into the bathroom and Pauling
cut down with a wrench and Cameron had the plumbers helper and Pauling had a wrench and he was lying
on the floor with working on the plumbing fixing Cameron's toilet so Cameron realized that he
didn't really need to be too careful about what he said or how Pauling was treated after that because
he recognized that Pauling was was not an aloof cerebral sort of person he didn't get his hand
sturdy so to speak so he mentioned one year maybe the first experience upon you had was of him
doing it to operate the piece of politics and I'm wondering if you could put a little bit more on
what you saw it and then in terms of his piece activism and the political thought of it of course
the end of the video well of course I myself was very much opposed to the Vietnam war my brother
was killed there as a fighter pilot in 1970 which really almost interfered with me resuming my
studies at Stanford because it was emotionally very difficult time and I had never understood the
logic of the war I didn't buy that domino theory that the administration time was promoting
with respect to we need stock communism Vietnam because then all all the countries in Southeast Asia
will become communist in Indonesia and Japan might be attacked and so forth I didn't buy that
explanation and it seemed to me that the war had been going on for a very long time and was
resulting in a lot of misery and I couldn't see how it was constructive I couldn't see a good
outcome so I I think had sentiments that were very similar to those espoused by Linus Pauling
at the time and Pauling of course as I learned had been an old hand in political activism originally
stimulated by his concern about proliferation of nuclear weapons and medical concerns about
the effect of widespread fallout from atomic bomb testing in the atmosphere so that that really
resonated very strongly with me there were some people at the institute who were even further left
and I would consider myself in some ways conservative in many ways liberal as well but there
were some people at the institute who were I would say probably extreme leftist and I remember
in particular after one of Pauling's talks at Stanford that was peace related there was quite a
lot of unhappiness among some people because Pauling had made the statement during this talk that
he believed that the retention of some nuclear weapons by both the Soviet Union and the
United States and the so-called mutually assured destruction principle had actually resulted
perhaps in deterrent from having a nuclear war conflagration so they were they were surprised
to hear him say that because I think some people had hoped that he would espouse the opinion that
we should destroy all weapons you know laterally and so forth but that's not what he said
in his lecture he said that he believed that having some of these weapons by opposing forces
would have probably resulted in a satisfactory stalemate because either side was
inhibited from using them knowing what would result from that first use of an atomic weapon
that was an atomic weapon he developed pretty early on in the 60s like he did in the 60s and in Paul.
Yeah and I heard him say that several times so he definitely was not
I would say he wasn't a pacifist because he said many times the World War II was well justified
and he as you know worked closely with the military to develop armaments and instruments that
helped the allied effort during World War II and he was certainly opposed to Hitler and Nazism
and I always saw him as a great patriot and it never occurred to me that great patriotism
and opposition to the Vietnam War or opposition to atmospheric testing of nuclear weapons was somehow
couldn't be reconciled and some people they didn't seem to be the mutual exclusive characteristics.
Were Paul and things something that came up around this could we often do we talk about that
with people in casual conversation with his colleagues or was it primarily more business oriented?
Pauling was not someone who engaged often in small talk so even in the many discussions that I had
with him he wasn't someone who liked to talk about pop culture or movies or music or literature or
anything of that nature he loved to talk about science and especially about things that he was
interested in and he loved to tell stories and most of the stories were related to things that
interested him from a scientific basis so I don't recall ever talking with him specifically about
any political activities and unfortunately I never thought to ask him more closely about some
of his political activities because there were always other things to talk about and I didn't
really query him much about his personal history when I knew him we were always talking about
current things or things that we were going to be doing in the future and not so much retrospective
issues except when he would tell me stories based on a current stimulating conversation that we
might be having but no he didn't generally talk about political issues with staff it was mainly
related to administrative issues and scientific issues well what was he like in the larger social
settings? Well in larger social settings he was often the the person that people gravitated to
he had a real charismatic personality kind of a magnetic personality he always had a big smile
he was very engaging very warmly greeted people in a social setting was physical shook hands
put his arm around people so he was he was very engaging and people responded to that and that's why
so many people loved him over the years and when he died in 1994 the institute collected hundreds
and hundreds of cards from people that didn't know Linus playing personally but had been deeply
affected by his death and were grieving and sharing their grief with us at the time
and everyone at the institute felt the same way as well I mean it was a really when he died in 1994
it was a very emotional moment for all of us because he just he had a way of generating a lot
of positive emotion about him and a lot of people loved him and respected him for different reasons
but he was a very jovial person he as I said he treated everyone fairly and equally I remember one
time when I was in the back parking lot of the institute Pauling was leaving the back door
and the janitor was arriving so it was after hours it was maybe five thirty or six in the afternoon
and the janitor was quite a way it's from the door I'd say maybe a hundred feet from the door
because janitor tended to park at the far end of the parking lot and Pauling stood there holding
the door open for probably three or four minutes while the janitor navigated this distance and came
into the building and then Pauling greeted him and then left the door and he was also holding a
box because he often used a box to ferry books and papers back and forth from the institute to his
apartment or ranch so he had something that in his arm as well and stood there holding the door
from the janitor and I think that was kind of symbolic in a way of the way he treated people he
was just very fair to everyone sometimes I think his excitement about scientific ideas that he
would generate in association with particular people caused him perhaps to overlook what might
some other people might consider problematic issues and personalities and I think that this
happened to him at least twice in his later years at the institute and both times it resulted in
personal clashes very unamicable departures of personnel from the institute and litigation which
was very difficult expensive and painful for everyone involved but I think he was so excited by
scientific talent that he tended to overlook some personality characteristics from time to time
but as I said he was a very warm engaging person I would go to birthday celebrations which occurred
I think every five years typically at hotel in San Francisco and there were other occasions at which
visitors were honored or the humanitarian award was given out or other awards were given out or
Pauling was an attendance for an award and he was always very very charming and people were
very happy to see him and he always had a big smile and greeting for everyone.
Any specific memories about those birthday celebrations?
Well the birthday celebrations were terrific the last one I remember was at Stanford
Court Hotel in San Francisco the mistress of ceremonies was Rita Moreno and I believe she
was approached by Rick Hicks to host that party because she had gotten an Emmy an OB atoni
and an Academy Award so Rick thought it was appropriate that someone who had been so honored
in so many of the performing fields was hosting an event for somebody who had been so honored
in so many medical and scientific and social fields like Linus Pauling and she was a real
firecracker and I think Linus Pauling really enjoyed listening to her talk and he had a lot of
his old friends there and it was it was always he always really enjoyed interacting with old colleagues
we also had a 20th anniversary celebration of the Linus Pauling Institute in 1993 at the
Ringsdorf House which was a Victorian House that had been renovated in the salt marsh area of
Mountain View California adjacent to Palo Alto and that was an opportunity to put on display a
lot of Pauling's awards medals honorary degrees and also invite supporters of the institute
institute staff and friends and some of Pauling's colleagues and friends who were still in the
Bay Area to come and see him and as it turned out it was probably the last time that some of these
people had an opportunity to meet him to see him again Owen Chamberlin was there a hard
McConnell from Stanford chemistry department had been a long friend of Pauling's and I think
instrumental in bringing Pauling to Stanford back in 1969 was there Byron Brown from Biosatistics
was there there were a number of people that Pauling had liked and associated with over the years
that were there and it provided him an opportunity to see them and greet them he always had a lot of
energy to meet people as well and in a very interesting way of speaking it was very characteristic and
a very characteristic way of moving as well both of which were captured quite realistically by John
Aston when he performed the part of Linus Pauling in the nature of the Marital Bond which was a play
put on in association when the Linus Pauling exhibition years ago
well he spent quite a lot of time of course with Rick Hicks and Emilzo Cacondole and I think
Rick was Rick really went out of his way to try to take care of Linus Pauling as well especially after
Avalon died really looked after his welfare and was interested in his personal health as well and I
think even tried to get Linus Pauling to exercise which is something that Pauling refused to do
and he talked quite often with Emilzo Cacondole mainly about administrative issues so with Rick Hicks
and Emilzo Cacondole there was a lot of talk about administrative issues and these kinds of
conversations went on for a decade or longer he saw quite a lot of hardened McConnell who was someone
he could talk about chemistry with and Henry Talby as well at Stanford and Zellik Herman was
another person that was a colleague and an employee of the institute but someone that Pauling could talk
in a very meaningful detailed way in depth about theoretical chemistry and structural chemistry
and physics so Herman and Pauling co-authored quite a few papers during this period in the 1970s to
the 1980s and up to the 1990s and I think Pauling relied on him to do a lot of the sort of the
heavy work in many of those papers so we spent a lot of time with Zellik Herman as well
and there were a lot of people that visited him who he'd known throughout his life
but he didn't really seem to have what I would call a strong social life of course
if he was entertaining people at his home in Porto Avali or at his apartment in Stanford I wouldn't
necessarily have known about that I mean I went to his home in Porto Avali a number of times he
and his wife used to host Christmas parties there and one of the last Christmas parties I went
to there I think was probably 1979 Avali and died in 1980 or 1981 81 so I believe that this was
probably about 1979 and I remember thinking about the egg nod that Pauling made which was really
extraordinarily good he wasn't a chef but having a Nobel prize winning chemist Nobel prize winning
chemist make the egg nod and spike it with with Avali it was pretty extraordinary it was a really
terrific treat and he when he was with his wife was also very affectionate and I think people picked
up on that affection and responded to that as well after his wife died of course there was no one
for him to be that affectionate with so he was a bit different in in social situations because
he didn't really have someone to to be affectionate with in those circumstances
She was a really diminutive person she was short she was very well spoken very articulate
and I enjoyed speaking with her when I talked to her several times she and I did not talk about
science so much as we talked about other issues and she as I found out later was particularly
fond of their association with some of the celebrities in in Los Angeles and Hollywood during the
era in which Pauling was trying to educate them about radioactive isotopes and nuclear weapons
and so forth and engaged in peace activities as well and we talked I think Avali and I talked
about those things sometimes but typically she was very close to her husband physically whenever
they were in a social environment and he always liked to steer the conversation to science so
the conversation typically would would end up being about science and not so much about some
of the other activities one of the thing about Pauling that I enjoyed was when I found out that he
enjoyed reading mystery novels I also was a big fan of Sherlock Holmes and not so much Agatha
Christie but particularly Rexed out and I asked him if he had read all of Sherlock Holmes and
Rexed out and of course he had so there wasn't anything I could loan him but there were other books
that I was reading he was not familiar with one was called The Red Right Hand by Joel Townsley Rodgers
which I think was written in 1939 or 1940 and it's a real hard boiled great detective story
and I loaned that to him and he really he loved that book very much and he consequently
loaned me books I would loan him books and he would he would loan me mystery books as well that
that he'd finished reading it was very interesting in and one time he he broke from that orthodoxy
and loaning me mystery novels and loaned me a book called Good Night Ava by Richard Bissell
and this was a 1950s pulp paperback with a painted cover and he said I think you'll enjoy this
and I got the book and I read it and it reminded me a little bit of Verscan Caldwell
even Mark Twain maybe and the cover of the book showed kind of a the sultry group
sitting on a on a porch of a kind of a ram shackle cabin probably in the banks of the Mississippi
River and there were a couple of guys lounging around looked like near-do wells and there was a
woman's trimming a guitar in not much on and she had her foot up on a pickle barrel or something
and I thought it was amusing that he'd loaned me this book and it was actually an amusing
entertaining read as well and I gave it back to him and when he when I gave it back to him his
eyes kind of sparkled a bit and he said did you notice anything particularly funny about the book
and I said yes and both of us burst out laughing he had taken a photograph of his wife
and cut out her face and pasted it over the face of the woman playing guitar and the
cover of the book and I thought that was very funny very appropriate since the the book had Ava
in the title as well you have that book I'm sure you do yeah and he had he had a terrific sense of
humor Zella Kerman likes to tell the story of the time that he was standing at the urinal
in the men's room at the Linus Pine Institute Science Medicine and Linus Pine came in and stood
next to him and looked over and said ah we meet his peers
so he was not prudish and of course Ken Hedberg has a very famous story of
when Ken was a graduate student at Caltech and was looking through one of those little plastic
viewfinders of the woman O'Natural in a stream standing on a rock or a boulder he was holding
this viewfinder up to the light and he heard Pauline's footsteps outside his office and thought oh
and Pauline came in and of course wanted to see what the viewfinder picture was and he held the
viewfinder up to the light and said ah the salt he'd identified the rock that she was standing on so
he had a great sense of humor and it was definitely was not prudish
um just backtracking briefly you mentioned me that Helen is talking about the connections that
they have with some of the Hollywood types do you call any individual which is particularly
fun about the women and stuff that no I don't but I remember there were a number of people who
came to the institute and also to some of Pauline's birthday events and other events
uh such as Eddie Albert I remember giving a tour to Eddie Albert and his son Eddie Albert Jr one
time at the institute and Carl Sagan came by one time for an event and there were a number of
other number of other people who escaped me right now who came through the institute and one
reason or another but those were I believe after a valentine died so those were people who had
continued to have some tidaline as Pauline or the one as Pauline's institute but I don't recollect
talking with her about specific people. Pauline by all accounts had a very difficult time feeling
and wondering if you have memories of that time period and how that fit in itself?
Well as Eric all he was gone quite a lot after her death uh I think he took a trip to Oregon
and visited some of his old boyhood haunts his home uh maybe the semi-family cemetery maybe
went to condon came here to Oregon State University he was perhaps didn't exhibit the same sort of
levity that that I was accustomed to seeing in him and in other words he was spontaneously happy
in the late 1970s when I saw him he always seemed to be very happy and uh very carefree
I think there was a more somber demeanor um that he exhibited after her death
and a lot of the sort of levity seemed to evaporate from his countenance at that time.
Now that's slowly returned over the course of the 1980s and I'd say by the
mid to late 1980s he seemed to be pretty much his old self in terms of a good sense of humor but
there was a period there when he didn't seem to be very happy.
Yeah that's fine.